[Music]
there are all kinds of situations where
we would love to have more control over
what the brain can do so that you have
these choices of what exactly you're
taking in what you're learning and and
where you're going with that and there
are also situations where we simply wish
that we could experience more say for
example that you would like to be able
to perceive things that we currently
can't perceive you want to be able to
see in the ultraviolet or you want to be
able to hear ultrasound or what if you
wanted to be able to uh remember more
things than you normally can
remember the most exciting part of the
future to me is the potential to achieve
humanistic intelligence this idea that
uh the late Marvin Minsky talked about
which is being able to create a an
environment where we have a symbiotic
relationship with artificial
intelligence uh and we will see a
blurring of our physical digital and
biolog iCal worlds uh not so much being
separate parts but as being seamless
parts of one integrated uh human
organism it probably will be possible to
read out what's inside a person's brain
to understand what's there by
translating it into something you can
understand and maybe even putting it
back giving it to someone
teaching when we make a decision now we
are under the impression that we are the
ones who making the decision and we make
it because we want to make it but if our
brains are connected to the net to a
computer Cloud um and there algorithms
there that are used in our decision
making well who's
deciding
[Music]
we are curious to understand who we are
and why we think the way we think and
what is what is uh the the reason of our
thoughts our memories our imagination
our
[Music]
feelings understanding this incredibly
complex organ that gives rise to
everything that makes us human
everything we see feel hear our sense of
identity and so given the vast
complexity of the brain you know 100
billion neurons you know hundreds of
trillions of connections um operating in
a dynamic Network that's constantly
changing it's just really uh uh very
very complicated system for for us to
study with science so it's a it's a big
challenge but one that's I really enjoy
undertaking in the human brain you have
about 3 million kilomet is a fibers is
connecting it so it's enough to go
around the Moon a couple of times just
in one
brain the place in the universe that is
likely the most complex and
mysterious the place where emotions
thoughts and memories
arise that place in the universe that
tries tireless ly to understand itself
an unsolved
Enigma we don't know and we cannot build
today anything that is even as closely
connected to as what we see in the in
the human
[Music]
brain there's one hypothesis that
suggests
that what brains are doing or what our
brain is doing is generating a virtual
reality a model of the world that is
running in our heads all the time this
has to do with ideas that have been
floating around in Philosophy for a few
centuries in particular with a
suggestion by Emmanuel Kant the German
philosopher that the reason why the
world and our minds our views of the
world
agree is not because our minds reflect
the world this is no no it's the
opposite is that the world is created by
our minds in other words that what we
perceive is not out there it's in
here it weighs less than 3 lb it
consumes scarcely 20 or 30 WTS of power
and nevertheless it's able to make
calculations more complex than a
supercomputer there are 100 to a,
trillion
synapses they about the size of a
bacteria they basically are chemical
machines they receive an electric pulse
and then they release chemicals they hit
receptors very complex Machinery is
triggered this uh results in a change in
the behavior of the neurons it causes
genes to express new proteins to come in
the Cascade of biochemical and
biophysical processes is enormously
complex if you would try to describe how
the networks of cells is working uh I
would say um that imagine that you are
having phone calls with 10,000 people at
one and the same time and the same what
you are doing everybody is doing who is
living on our planet planet on the earth
about 7 billion people and when you then
try to describe all this communication
that is going on of all the 7 billion
people and then you imagine that this is
only one1 perhaps um of the capacity and
everything is only within your skull is
restricted to one and a half kilogram
and this is complexity in my
view
[Music]
in spite of a 100 Years of uh
Neuroscience we still don't understand
how the brain works we still don't have
a general theory of the function of the
[Music]
brain the first reason why I would argue
is critical to to understand how the
brain works has to do with our own
definition as human beings we are a
mental species we are defined by our
minds not by our bodies so we are a very
special type of animal we don't
understand the organ that generates our
minds so when we understand how the
brain works we will be able to
understand how our mind is from the
inside and we'll understand ourselves
for the first
[Music]
time the second reason has to do with a
clinic with patients humankind should
understand how the brain works because
we need uh it's urgent that we help
these patient that have mental and
neurological diseases and we have to
understand the the the system in order
to fix
it
we estimate that possibly one person out
of two to one person out of three in
Europe have some kind of uh disorder
that is related to the brain altogether
it's maybe up to more than 200 million
person in Europe who have one of those
disorder and it's also associated with a
huge cost for the society the cost of
all disease affecting the brain more
than the cost of all cancer plus all
cardiovascular disease plus
diabetes and then the third reason has
to do with technology and the economy
and it is very likely that brains not
just of humans but brains of all animals
have discovered through hundreds of
millions of years of
evolution ways to compute that could be
much more efficient I and powerful than
what we're doing currently with our
digital computers so if this is the case
if we understood if we were able to
break this neural code and understand
how the brain computes what are the
algorithms that are present in our
nervous systems we will likely
revolutionize uh computer science
computer technology and I would say the
economy at the same
time
the holy grof of this will be to create
a much more symbiotic relationship with
artificial intelligence as we can see
today artificial intelligence is moving
forward in Leaps and Bounds offering us
a a myriad of new ways of being more
productive and more efficient in how we
conduct our businesses and how we manage
our daily lives with the introduction of
more and more devices that actually
understand the human and help humans
optimize their own performance we will
have a way to create a much more a
different type of intelligence what I
would call humanistic intelligence the
distinction between the biological world
the physical world and the digital
worlds will just blur and we will
intergate seamlessly across all of these
dimensions a deep understanding of the
functioning of the human brain could
bring answers to Great philosophical
questions such as what Consciousness is
and how it is built or if there is Free
Will Concepts such as the inner self
guilt or even reality could change
forever we are opening the door to a
world where we will communicate directly
with a computer through thought a world
where we will be able to share our
thoughts and our emotions through the
internet we can Envision a future in
which we are able to read the thoughts
of others and even to to manipulate
them we're building technology to read
the activity of all the neurons in these
brains and to write activity to control
and manipulate the activity of these
Nears in the brain and these
Technologies are necessary to be able to
cure human
patients but the same technology
technology is neutral it could be used
for good or for bad the same
Technologies to read and write activity
into brains can be used to
decipher what people are thinking or to
influence the uh activity of the minds
of of people so you say well this is
science fiction well not
really in the middle of the '90s the
last decade of the 20 20th century and
the second Millennium a whole revolution
in the world of Neuroscience occurred
the neuroimaging techniques
appeared so neuroimaging techniques are
important for this um revolution in how
to learn and explore the brain because
it's a nice noninvasive way to get
inside the brain one of the Imaging
techniques that had the greatest impact
was magnetic resonance imaging
for the first time ever we could see the
inner functioning of the brain while it
experiences Sensations and
emotions in fact functional magnetic
resonance imaging able to detect the
presence of oxygen in the blood in the
brain has allowed us to discover
something unimaginable years ago how
different areas in the brain interact
while the patient talks season it image
listens to a sound or simply
thinks but if you ask him to focus on
one task like listening to a sound only
the region from this specific task the
auditory cortex for example will have
more conception of oxygen and this
region will pop out in the contrast if
you analyze the data ear listening to
sound against non listening to
sound the reason why we don't understand
how the brain works is not because of
its complexity but because we've been
lacking methods to stud it at the right
level now if you think about it trying
to understand a system as complex as the
brain that has a 100 billion neurons by
recording from one neuron it's a little
bit like trying to watch a movie in a TV
screen that has a million pixels by
looking at a single Pixel so no matter
for how long you study a single Pixel or
just study single neon you will be
missing the figures in the screen and
the shapes of the images because they
are an emerging property of the
correlations in space and time between
the individual
[Music]
pixels that we think that Neuroscience
should embark on this period of new
technology to develop the method so that
neuroscientists and clinicians will be
able to see for the first time in the
future the activity of complete neural
circuits and be able to decipher the
functional meaning of this
pattern how can one measure the activity
of each and every one of the neurons in
a brain at the same time the methods
that we and many other people are using
are Optical methods we use light because
light can penetrate the tissue in a
non-invasive fashion in particular the
method that I Pioneer is called calcium
Imaging that we used it for the first
time to measure the activity of neural
circuits every time a neuron fires every
time it's activated calcium comes into
the neuron so that means if you have
these little calcium indicators these
fluorescent molecules in all the neurons
you can directly see who is firing who's
being activated in the entire group at
once because you see this as changes in
fluorescent that are happening in
different earons at different
times thanks to neuroimaging techniques
we have learned more about the brain in
the last 15 years than in the whole
history of hum
kind the advances already made allow us
to think that in the near future we will
be able to solve neurological damage
diseases like Parkinson's or Alzheimer's
depression or schizophrenia yeah I think
that the revolution we're experiencing
now is first the the birth and the
success of human Neuroscience we now
have Fields like cognitive Neuroscience
where we use functional brain Imaging
and non-invasive brain stimulation to
study the functioning human brain and
that was I think the first
step
[Music]
from my perspective I've been doing neur
Neuroscience research for 30 years and
this is the the revolution now but now
is the time that Neuroscience is
starting to reach into people's lives
directly and to me that's what we need
uh to have a revolution we need to
advance from the lab into the real
world
this is a software application to be
able to control the puzzle box orbit
I'll first connect it to the emotive
Insight EEG
headset and that's now connected what we
have to do is train two patterns um the
first is a resting state so that we
understand when you want to control the
the orbit versus not and and then the
second pattern is to control what you
want to apply for flying the
orbit
this leap from the lab to the real world
can already be seen in the form of the
perfecting of what belonged to the realm
of Science Fiction just a few years ago
brain computer
Association the so-called brain machine
interfaces have solidified this
revolution in the world of the
Neuroscience well BCI really just means
brain computer interface so anything
that makes a connection between
processing going on inside your brain
and a machine uh some other
device brain computer interfaces can be
grouped as a group of technologies that
can help both from a hardware and
software perspective able to both decode
process and
activate the interf interactions between
humans and machines decoding the brain
of course typical defition would be a
platform that can help us interact from
the brain to the world
the brain machine interfaces are
bringing great advances in various
therapeutical
applications up to now one of the main
practical applications is the treatment
of different pathologies associated with
paralysis
at the federal Polytechnic School of
loan Switzerland Dr Jose Milan has been
working for years on an ambitious
Project based on the development of a
brain machine interface that allows
paralytics to control a robotic
exoskeleton with their minds thanks to
which they can walk again or move a
hand the patients wear an electrode
helmet that detects their cerebral
electrical
activity what we ask ask people to do at
the very beginning because they need to
go through a training in order to
acquire the capability to modulate
voluntarily their brain signals is to
imagine the movement that they want to
accomplish and this requires some
sometimes because it is not easy to do
that our algorithms are capable to
discover which are the areas the
specific areas that they are activating
and deactivating at which frequencies
this is happening and this is the input
to our machine learning algorithms that
will build the model of the decoder that
will differentiate a opening a closing
of the hand a right step a left step and
so on and so forth so during this
training people at the very beginning
need to imagine the movement of their
own body and in many cases people after
some training and because the fact that
as they imagine a movement of their body
this is executed via the exoskeleton
they don't need to think any longer
about their own body they think in terms
of the exoskeleton because the
exoskeleton has been integrated somehow
in people's uh body es schema that we
have in our
brain the possibilities that this
technique offers to these patients have
allowed to a quadriplegic p patient to
be able to drive a Formula 1 car just
with his
mind in
2017 Rodrigo hubner Mendes became the
first person to reach such a milestone
this opportunity to work with Rodrigo
was incredible globo um TV in Brazil
created a vehicle a Formula 1 vehicle
that was completely controlled just
using the power of thought so what they
used was our 14 channel epoch plus
headset uh measuring electrical
fluctuations from Rodrigo's brain he
spent a few months mapping and training
the algorithms to understand how he
Associated specific thoughts whether it
be drive forward right turn right left
or stop and then he was able to use
those commands to drive this car
completely just using his mind so no
steering wheel no pedals just him in
inside the
vehicle this was a very fatuous moment
when Lewis Hamilton who is obviously the
world's reigning F1 Champion was in the
same place as Rodrigo in the UAE Rodrigo
posed a very exciting challenge for
Lewis which is would you like to race me
surprisingly Lewis accepted the
challenge so I I'm not sure when we're
going to start seeing the two of them
start practicing but I know that Rodrigo
is very excited about the ability and
the the opportunity to race with the
reigning world champion just using his
mind around the world a wide variety of
projects based on brain machine
interfaces are currently being
developed in Boston the company
neuroelectrics has developed a
Technology based on the use of Mind
controlled video games to learn to
regulate brain
activity okay so uh today we are going
to measure your brain waves with this
device uh this device basically uses dry
electrodes to measure your brain waves
like this mhm and today we are going to
measure your specifically your Alpha
brain waves and you're going to be able
to control an object in this screen
going up and down so I'm going to put
you the
cup
then we are first going to measure your
Baseline which is the Baseline of your
brain waves the level in which your
brain is right
now so the way we have developed our
brain computer interface is we are
collecting brain signals for example
alpha or beta or gamma which are
different frequencies right we are
coupling your brain or power Spectrum
your brain bands to Something in the
screen which is in this case a little
Avatar that goes up and down according
to if your brain waves are up or
down so this summering here this is
going up and down according to your
brain waves and you are controlling it
so you need to focus on it and keep
relaxed and try to control it moving it
up and
down
the Mind controlled video games are
proving to be an efficient treatment for
diseases like depression or
hyperactivity disorder in
children at neuroscape a
neurotechnological company based in San
Francisco they are using these video
games controlled by the mind for
therapeutic
uses all of our research right now
relies on using the uh Clos Loop video
games that we've created uh so far just
using the performance not the cognitive
brain computer interface that's still
very much a research in the research
phase and then we apply these uh these
closed loop video game treatments to see
if they can improve attention abilities
in many different clinical populations
including ADHD which is attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder but also
post-traumatic stress disorder traumatic
brain injury depression and autism we
developed these closed loop video games
that record your performance and use
that data to challenge you in a very
personalized manner so if it's too hard
uh the game could back off if it's too
easy it could make it more challenging
just puts it right at that sweet spot
and then the game mechanics Target
different neural networks that we're
trying to improve so it could be a
prescribable treatment just like we
currently use stimulants to help improve
attention abilities in children that are
suffering
ADHD
[Music]
in the last few years there has been a
progressive blossoming of neurotech
startups that are revolutionizing the
way to intervene in our mental
processes nowadays most of them are
focused on helping patients with
different types of damage or
neurological disorders however in the
not so distant future these companies
will end up transferring all these
advances to our daily lives radically
modifying the way we interact with each
other and even understand the
world investing in novel neurot
technology today could be the best way
to generate an economic revolution in
the future by the development of this
new
technology which instead of
biotechnology in the case of the Human
Genome Project now it would be neurot
technology and this is something that's
starting to happen happen uh last year
uh Elon Musk created a NE Technology
Company New Link Brian Johnson another
billionaire has created a similar uh
company called kernel so we starting to
have some uh new companies that are
based on the promise that these new
neurot technologies are going to be
cause an economic
Revolution a is a neuroinformatics
company so what we do is we're a
platform that allows us to interface
directly with the brain today it's using
non-invasive methods so we start from
the sensor input so measuring the brain
activity itself through to the
translation of the electrical signals
from the brain and then we map those to
control and influence the environment
around us look at your brain
Kim so you're wearing a 14 channel EEG
and this is just picking up electrical
fluctuations that result from neurons
firing inside your brain the brain is
made up of billions of neurons and when
they interact the chemical reaction just
emits an electrical impulse that we can
pick up you can see that different parts
of your brain is lighting up depending
on what you might be thinking or whether
you're paying attention to what I'm
saying so what we're doing here is we're
mapping those electrical fluctuations
into a 3D uh model of what your brain is
doing and each of the colors represent a
different frequency band which indicates
how fast the information is traveling
one from one part of the brain to
[Music]
another located in Lon Switzerland in
the center of Europe is the head
quarters of Mind ma one of the largest
neurotechnological companies in the
world and our big goals are really to
disrupt um industries from Healthcare so
really improving quality of life after a
neurological injury all the way to being
able to help uh healthy individuals you
know enable the ability of their brain
to learn to play to and interact
entertain one of those Technologies
designed to help the rehabilitation of
Pat patients who have suffered stroke is
mind motion
Pro it's the first device a stroke or a
brain brain injury patient sees after
the injury you know the first two days
when they come out and they need to
recover it's one of the first devices
that's able to start training of both
the brain and the body way so it's about
neuroplasticity tricking the
brain so we're going to put markers on
you so that the
camera can see your arms while we do
some
activity so it's pretty intuitive you'll
just need to move your hand to the start
button and similarly if you move it in
the direction that isn't indicated
you'll see how to correct it so let's
say someone who has a stroke cannot move
the left hand and he can move the right
hand the camera in the mind motion Pro
Tracks the right right hand and puts it
on an avatar on the left side and then
the brain suddenly says oh something's
happening there so I should try more it
starts activating the pathways that used
to control that hand and slowly it
accelerates
recovery the latest and most ambitious
proposal of Mind Bay the cogn chip goes
one step further and merges
neurotechnology with artificial
intelligence
some entrepreneurs are looking into
augmenting our brains so that we can
develop super intelligence that allows
us to collaborate with artificial
intelligence it would be a way to reduce
the risk for human beings to become
irrelevant due to the rise of artificial
intelligence
it is the next Frontier neuroscience and
neurotechnology brain technology is
definitely the next Frontier now we
truly are at the frontier where we can
do some impactful things with the brain
so yeah neurotechnology is now really
going to kick
off ignition sequence start 6 5 4 3 2 1
zero all engine
running one of the greatest
technological and scientific milestones
in history was the arrival of man on the
[Music]
moon the Kennedy era was one of the
periods of the greatest scientific
Splendor the world has ever known as a
consequence an important economy grew
around it which led in a very short time
to unprecedented technological
development
ideas are what power our economy we do
Innovation better than anybody
else and that makes our economy stronger
we had had many interactions with um the
White House Office of Science and
Technology policy and they had explained
to us that they were interested in Grand
challenges for the US government to
pursue any different areas of science
that they thought could really be of the
same ilk as for instance the Apollo moon
landings a big project that really would
allow the entire us Community to get
behind something that would make a huge
impact in
science they found that great science
project in the brain initiative a
research Mega project that Obama
announced in 2013 with the goal of
unveiling the mysteries of the
brain it's a very exciting moment uh
there are many groups around the world
developing new methods and this is now
leading to a re-energizing of
Neuroscience and to the perception that
we can really do it that this is doable
that we can actually end up being able
to record the activity of every in a
brain and decipher it and this could
really revolutionize Neuroscience just
like the Human Genome Project
revolutionized
genetics very soon after the launching
of the brain and initiative the European
Union announced its own Mega project the
human brain
project it turns out that similar
initiatives have been created in
different countries so there is a a
brain initiative in Japan in Canada in
China in Australia South Korea and
Israel the development of all these
projects could change the scenario of
brain research and Lead Humanity to
unprecedented advances so this is very
exciting this is just happening and I
hope that this will provide the ability
to generate uh knowledge and send this
knowledge throughout the world and
different countries uh in a way in which
no one is Left Behind and we're all part
of the same exciting moment in in
history
we've started the path to a new world in
which a deeper knowledge of the brain
will radically transform our Human
[Music]
Condition
brain machine communication will grow
progressively more efficient and precise
and will open up a vast range of
possibilities for human beings to
benefit from the potential offered to us
by artificial
[Music]
intelligence with the um introduction of
more and more devices that actually
understand the human and help humans
optimize their own performance we will
have a way to create a much more a
different type of intelligence what I
would call humanistic intelligence the
idea is that you can create a a a myriad
of devices and sensors around us that
interface and interplay with artificial
intelligence in a way that makes humans
um much more symbiotic with their
environment so you know the distinction
between the biological world the
physical world and the digital worlds
will just blur and we will integrate
seamlessly across all of these
Dimensions so you know when you feel
confused your AI will recognize that and
will prompt you with commands if it
recognize that you're fatigued it'll
send a command to brew the coffee pot or
a message to your phone reminding you to
go out and take a short walk and stretch
your legs so you will become integrated
with your environment and your
environment becomes an extension of your
brain and I think that type of
humanistic intelligence is really where
we're going to see the future
go the cognitive capacities of human
beings will be
enhanced there are experiments by
colleagues um such as Roy Ken kados that
have shown that you can improve
numerical abilities uh in children um
that have U this culia people uh who
have difficulty in in um in doing
arithmetic and so on I think enhancement
via uh implants um and things like this
is definitely going to be possible
Technologies are going to enable humans
to augment ourselves mentally just like
holding an iPhone we can have access to
enormous amount of information if that
comes directly piped into our brains
we're going to be able to operate at the
cognitive level above what we operate
that normally so they're going to be
augmented humans so this uh uh could
cause
major difference in the society can
accentuate the difference between
different social groups of different
countries and we have to ensure that
there's equal access to all of that that
there's a principle of furnace that runs
across the application of these new
neurot technologies and artificial
intelligent
algorithms it gets more interesting when
you can think about neuroprosthesis in
the cognitive parts of the brain so
let's take for instance this hipocampal
prosthesis the patients who are going to
be the first ones to use these devices
are going to be the first people with
some kind of superhuman memory ability
the very first type of memory ability is
going to be that they can choose when
they do remember something and when they
don't because they can say okay the
stuff that I the experiences that were
coming through at 3:00 yesterday
I want those to be
[Music]
enhanced brain computer communication
Will Make Way for brain computer brain
interfaces you take what this person has
learned you run it through the
translator and you give it to someone
else's brain or you just want to be able
to communicate through something like
telepathy you can read out what a person
is trying to say or what they're Imaging
what they're imagining and you can try
to give those imaginings or those sounds
to someone
else
you could try to detect what a person is
feeling and you can translate that in a
way and then give it to someone else so
you can imagine this as a as a
communication pathway that wouldn't just
work for words but it would work for
images it would work for feelings it
would work for anything that we share in
in a sense where we can say because
we're all humans we all have feelings of
happiness and of sadness and of pain and
we have smell and we have Vision so you
can you can transfer smells you can
transfer Vision you can transfer
auditory you can eventually with enough
translation even translate knowledge and
memory connecting brains is going to be
is going to be done um there are
definitely hurdles and it's going to
take very important technological
breakthroughs I think the in in the
future we will definitely have uh very
powerful synthetic telepathy
Technologies
it will be possible not only to read
others thoughts but also to manipulate
them let's think about it a little bit
more about the the impact and
repercussions of this new knowledge to
society to humanity
now we can uh using mice we cannot read
the activity of every near in the brain
of house but if you look at the visual
cortex you can actually read the
activity a few thousand neurons there
and we can uh deher some of the patterns
of activity as they relate to what the
animal is is seeing what the animal is
looking at and then we can go in with
Optical methods with optogenetics and
selectively change the patterns of
activity and fool the animal into
thinking that he's seeing one thing or
the other thing by essentially playing
the piano with this neural circuits in
the visual cortex of the of the brain
this is something we can do
today people could do this with uh with
humans not today we don't have the
methods to control to read the activity
of of uh of many neurons in the brain of
humans and to change that but this me
these methods are going to be developed
because we need them for the patients in
fact uh there's a project
supported by DARPA by the foundation of
of military research to build a
electronic chip to record the activity
of 1 million
neurons in a human in a human patient
and to stimulate a 100,000 neurons at
the same time and this is not science
fiction this is something that's been
built as we
speak in fact we're helping to build
them because they need to use this for
for patients and this could be in the
clinic in four
years A Whole New World of opportunities
is opening up before our eyes a world
where we will have the ability to
co-evolve with artificial
intelligence there is even a hypothesis
that in the distant future we won't need
our biological structures if all we are
are our thoughts our memories our
emotions our whole self self can be
transferred into a computer our
biological bodies will no longer be
necessary so now we're getting into the
more far future science fiction aspect
of this whole Endeavor there is a
science fiction term called Mind
uploading what it means is that mind or
who we are is then no longer dependent
on the biological brain as such you
still need a brain of course there's no
such such thing as as no device running
your mind but it could be all sorts of
devices it could be a device that is
better suited for say for example living
in space or living on another planet or
living underwater or something like
that so when you get to a far future
where the technology of whole brain
emulation which is really the the more
scientific concept what is it you're
actually doing here you're trying to
emulate what's going on in the circus
when you have that then you can start
thinking about the personal and social U
consequences of doing that which is
really what mind uploading means it's a
it's a very philosophical term in a
sense it's like what happens if you can
take who I am my mind and move me to
something else so many things are then
potentially possible you could make
backups of your mind so that if
something happens you can restore and
it's not a you know it's not as
devastating
[Music]
the knowledge we have acquired in recent
years about the brain has given us
possibilities until recently considered
science fiction we're advancing at very
high speed we can't know where a deeper
knowledge of the brain will lead us but
it's in our hands to steer it in the
right
direction it's critical
to have uh guidelines ethical guidelines
for the development of these
Technologies we propose to add to the
human Universal Declaration of Human
Rights new uh rights to protect
individuals from the abuse of neurot
Technologies and artificial intelligence
so this is what we call the neural
rights and they have to do with
protecting uh the mental privacy of
people so this is our first one not just
the data privacy of our phon no no the
mental privacy our thoughts and even
worse our subconscious thoughts things
that we don't even know we're not aware
of of knowing them those should be
protected it should be a and this is the
ultimate human right the our mental
privacy we should also have protection
as we connect ourselves to uh computers
through brain computer interfaces look
at the effect that connecting us to the
net through our iPhones has had in our
culture well imagine if that connection
could be direct through some uh brain
computer interface that could be maybe
uh Wireless and uh and um non-invasive
that could happen in the future so uh so
this is going to affect our sense of
identity of who we are we need to to
protect the sense of of identity the ey
the self this is something that humans
never have to worry about in the past no
one ever had that problem
[Music]
before related to this is also our sense
of agency our free will it could be
someone who wants to actually change the
way you're you're operating so that's
another
fundamental right that has to be
protected so these are the the neurites
now we have to convince uh um the
leaders of the world and the leaders of
the society that this is a very
important issue we're discussing the
future of our society the future of
human humankind and that we have to make
sure that these Technologies which are
so powerful and they could uh cause so
much uh good uh not just impatience but
in among ourselves we be able to finally
understand who we are it's like a new
Renaissance that these Technologies are
not used against us um we have to be uh
Vigilant and we just have to put this
ethical framework in place so that this
doesn't
happen this understanding is just going
to give us the tools to develop in many
different directions to explore in many
directions and also to be versatile and
adaptable so that maybe the human
species has a really long-term future
not the kind of future where you know it
works for a while and then we're not
adapted well enough and that's it but a
really long-term future that's what I'm
hoping that this could ultimately lead
to I hope it could provide us with the
tools to have basically what you might
call another Cambrian explosion where
the new species develop in all kinds of
directions except it's us it's uh the
human species deciding that we want to
try out this direction try out that
direction and so
forth
[Music]
science can change the world it can
change society it can change the course
of history and it can do that for good
or for bad it's up to us to make sure
that it it goes uh in the right
direction we've entered a new age the
age of Neuroscience in age in which the
way we experience and feel the world
will radically
change welcome
to the World of
[Music]
Tomorrow